salut les épis curieux et les épicurieux
aujourd'hui on parle de l'un des plats
préférés des français le couscous mais
savez-vous d'où il vient tout le monde
n'est pas d'accord du Maroc de l'Algérie
vous allez voir que c'est un petit peu
plus compliqué que cela
bienvenue dans sur la planche si vous
aimez ce format n'hésitez pas à liker et
à vous abonner de cette manière je
pourrai continuer à vous faire saliver
le couscous les Français en consomme
chaque année tenez-vous bien
80 minutes et nous ne sommes pas les
seuls à adorer ce plat emblématique des
pays du Maghreb on en mange partout dans
le monde alors pour la plupart des
historiens sa naissance remonte au
Moyen-Âge le couscous serait né dans la
partie
occidentale du Maghreb une région qui
correspond aujourd'hui au territoire du
Maroc et de l'Algérie du coup l'un et
l'autre en revendique la paternité pour
les Marocains aucun doute le couscous
est un plat maison ce qui est évidemment
fait bondir les Algériens alors qui a
raison qui a tort je suis désolé mais il
est impossible de trancher et pour cause
à l'époque où le couscous a été inventé
le Maroc et l'Algérie n'existe pas enfin
n' pas sous leur forme actuelle le
Maghreb occidental est essentiellement
peuplé le tribu berbère souvent nomade
ou semi nomades qui ne sont pas
rattachés à un territoire particulier ce
dont on est sur en revanche c'est que le
mot couscous vient de l'arabe couscous
et j'espère que je prononce bien il est
apparu pour la première fois au 12e
siècle dans les livres de cuisine alors
on entend dire parfois que ce mot fait
référence au bruit que faisait les
bracelets des femmes qui manipulaient la
semoule couscous mais bon je l'ai trouvé
aucune source qui la teste ce mot
désigne à la fois le plat et la semoule
il s'agit d'une tradition ancestrale qui
s'est transmise de génération en
génération dans certaines régions le
couscous était aussi appelé Tam
nourriture en arabe ou céréales logique
car la semoule on le rappelle est
produite à partir de blé dur différents
du blé tendre avec lequel on fait du
parcours être complet
dans certains endroits la semoule était
parfois remplacée par de l'orge ou des
miettes de pain on trouve donc de tout
dans le couscous c'est un plat très
équilibré si bien qu'au 13e siècle il
est fortement recommandé par les traités
arabes de médecine le plat connaît un
tel succès qu'il va se diffuser au gré
des mouvements de population dans tout
le bassin méditerranéen ou de la du
Maghreb occidental on consomme en Égypte
on Proche et au Moyen-Orient mais aussi
en Europe il débarque sur notre
continent par l'Espagne et le Portugal
il faut dire que ces deux pays ont été
sous domination arabes musulmanes
pendant plus de sept siècles en France
on ne le découvre que bien plus tard il
s'invite à la table des Français au
milieu du 20e siècle à partir des années
50-60 traverse la Méditerranée au moment
de l'indépendance de l'Algérie et du
Maroc et maintenant que vous êtes
incollable sur l'origine du couscous il
est temps de passer aux travaux
pratiques enfin à table direction la
cuisine
en fait il n'y a pas un couscous mais
dès couscous traditionnellement il est
composé de viande au singulier ou au
pluriel de l'agneau en priorité c'est le
couscous que l'on déguste au Maroc ou en
Algérie mais si vous n'aimez pas
l'agneau vous pouvez le déguster avec du
bœuf
ou du poulet
et si vous avez vraiment beaucoup
d'appétit vous pouvez même réunir toutes
ces viandes les légumes maintenant je
voudrais pas casser l'ambiance mais t'as
pas oublié un truc
essentiel genre les gazmer mais oui
on peut aussi agrémenter ce plat avec
des merguez indispensables pour réaliser
un couscous royal je précise cependant
une chose c'est qu'à l'origine il n'est
pas très populaire au Maghreb car les
merguez tels qu'on les connaît
aujourd'hui c'est à dire une saucisse à
base de viande de mouton hachée et une
invention française voilà je peux
revenir aux légumes maintenant ok c'est
bon tu peux y aller au menu
carotte comme de terre courgettes
oignons on peut aussi mettre des navets
ou du chou on oublie surtout pas
les pois chiches non seulement c'est
excellent roux mais c'est aussi très bon
pour la santé ils sont riches en
protéines en vitamines et aussi en
fibres la viande les légumes il ne
manque plus qu'une chose la semoule on
l'a dit elle est obtenue à partir de blé
dur les grains sont débarrassés de
l'enveloppe qui les entourent et
concassées attention pas trop finement
il ne s'agit pas d'en faire de la farine
on doit sentir le grain mais pas trop
quand même le tout est ensuite séché et
tamisé dans certains pays comme le
Sénégal la semoule de manioc remplace
celle de blé et on mange même du
couscous de maïs au Brésil aujourd'hui
on ajoute aussi
des raisins secs alors une figure pas
dans la recette traditionnelle mais
cette petite touche sucrée n'est pas
désagréable au mot vous avez toujours
faim alors voici un couscous plus
original allez on dégage la viande
l'agneau le poulet les merieses et le
bœuf on garde les légumes et la semoule
qui vont accompagner
du poisson en général on y trouve de la
dorade du cabillaud du mulet ou de la
rascasse ce couscous est excellent ils
viennent de Tunisie on le retrouve aussi
très souvent dans la cuisine sicilienne
enfin vous pouvez aussi vous passer de
protéines animales et vous contentez des
légumes et de la semoule des pois
chiches bien sûr car ce sont les seuls
qui vont vous apporter les protéines
nécessaires à notre organisme
tu as encore oublié un ingrédient
essentiel mais bien sûr
Larissa
cette petite sauce petite mais très
forte est obtenue à partir de piment
Larissa de l'arabe arazak qui signifie
écraser billets au passage si vous
voulez savoir pourquoi le piment brûle
pourquoi il arrache la comme on dit et
bien reportez-vous à la vidéo que nous
avons fait sur le sujet et qui se trouve
ici en général il faut délayer Larissa
dans un petit peu de bouillon avant d'en
arroser la semoule quoi qu'il en soit
tout ceci est excellent celui qui a
préparé tous ces ingrédients aurait très
bien eu sa place au couscous Fest c'est
le championnat du monde de couscous qui
a lieu chaque année au mois de septembre
à San Vito le capot en Sicile le titre
est actuellement détenu par des Italiens
ils ont remporté la victoire avec un
couscous froid crevette et au gaspacho
l'année précédente il appartenait à une
chef roumaine qui avait proposé un
couscous à base d'agneau de rhubarbe et
de jaune elle avait elle-même ravi le
titre à une sénégalaise qui avait séduit
le jury avec un couscous à base de
mangue et de poulpe vous voyez on est
très loin de la recette traditionnelle
mais c'est aussi ça le couscous la
rencontre de culture différente qui se
sont enrichis les unes les autres
et voilà chers
que cette vidéo vous a plu et que je
vous ai donné envie de partager un bon
couscous entre amis en attendant
n'hésitez pas à liker cette vidéo et à
nous suggérer d'autres idées de plats en
commentaire vous pouvez compter sur moi
je suis prêt à vous concocter d'autres
vidéos allez à très bientôt
[Musique]